damn gum Prospera welcome cells go
what as weird as it sounds is amnesia
meets Pikmin I can't go in here so well
I guess we're going here oh my god I
feel so weird to be back in the Misha
you bros always like one more Tunisia
why would anyone think Pokemon an
amnesia but [ __ ] it let's click the orb
Pikachu is how you pick it you pick it
big what's happening
Pikachu maybe two now stop it Pikachu
this is not like you Jesus wait am i a
Pokemon ah damn it
[ __ ] hell plot twist I'll pick at you
hey Pierre chop what are you doing the
[ __ ] was that
oh wait is the idiot
alright I'm going in there then ah never
mind then what the [ __ ] ah ah it's
shaking so much
Wow I can broke my face
pick a pig Oh God it's empty
I can help you okay I trust my move all
right well I don't see why I wouldn't
trust a bucks go bucks a jack yes I
think I'll stick with you for a while
surely isn't safe out here yeah best
game ever
hey Jake hey that's what you wear you go
I don't trust you and never trusted you
ah but I just use a box as a Pokemon I
think yes I think potentially game of
the Ahmad okay some Oh I'm just walking
around kind of like forest ah a barrel
get him boxy get him boxy yes rat stupid
barreled [ __ ] heat oh god he you
swine splat it's super effective under
my butt oh god box you know
now boxing love you used to box or going
down [ __ ] barrel gets right
that's right my box to go [ __ ] you up
ah do tell god he's gonna bind splat me
no no no no it's a briefing damn it buck
see alright we find another enemy now
boxy I love you
I love you two points shut up shut up
buck sorry did we win yes my box level
up one exp he needs for XP to next level
am i evolving huh you can you can
involved your books yes yes oh I'm
freaking the day huh yes bookshelf
bookshelf I'm so proud of your box so
proud
oh god nothing wines flat it's still
super effective god dammit I stopped
wine splatting me don't die don't die
thank God it [ __ ] are up come on back
mark mark oh yes a fire brush what am i
evolving again two barrel no no no no no
what what's have I done what have I done
no no Roxy now you're not one of them no
all right barrel versus barrel you can
now use wine splat Oh which is pretty
awesome
we both wine splattered on each other
strike furnace you could burn in hell
for all I care furnace my barrels gonna
beat your ass I don't care I don't care
if he's evil
it's mine I don't care if he's ugly
either it's my son and I love him cheap
wine splatting barrel
damn it Jess that was close
where's the chair huh yeah yes why are
you
I'm with the bailiffs now just blow it's
not effective huh you're like a [ __ ]
magic harp visitor a bit you change
peers it changed
that's right [ __ ] [ __ ] you up oh my god
a table
I never thought I would find a table I'm
so sorry table whoa Navin 11:4 my barrel
eyes on the set box I mean box it's a
box it's a box oh thank God we made it
out all right boss battle time brush we
are so ready I want to earn that Pokemon
gem Oh
oh my god never seven servant once plant
oh go barrel boo I love you it's not
effective what oh my god I a box our
attack missed oh no doc dark slash no
dear barrel now okay okay uh I'm down me
now well chat didn't work yeah Pikachu
Pikachu I'm gonna have to fight to be
struck I'm stronger this enemy I can
become alright fine I'll become a table
you're now a badass table oh all right
all right give me the best wine splash
you got yes I don't care if it's
ineffective you smoke yeah well I'll use
dust blow baby
super effective Wow
is it covered in smoke just blow that
[ __ ]
oh go table go table oh no it missed
dammit
keep dust oh no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no we're gonna die no
[ __ ] don't die don't die don't die don't
die don't die die die die dead oh my god
how are you kidding me
Oh table now demo yeah just ah is the
greatest moment I'm a laugh Pokemon
amnesia
best game ever yes yes yes Wow alright
press that was Pokemon MD chef or
monsters very cool mod I really enjoyed
it hope you bros enjoy it as well
please leave a like and I really
appreciate it and I'll see you in the
next one stay awesome
you